- [Voiceover] I bought a samurai sword.
Didn't even remember until I received
and opened the package.
That was a fun day.
(whoosh)
(hinge squeaks)
("All Night Polka")
(beer pours)
- [Voiceover] $180 worth of fake urine.
My brother and I drunk-discussed
it for about an hour.
In the end, it seemed like a good idea.
- [Voiceover] A circus-themed
tent for my cat.
(meow)
It has a tiny flag on top.
- [Voiceover] I bought a
six cup food processor,
a pair of knee-high bumblebee socks,
and a coloring book called
"Dinosaurs with Jobs."
- [Voiceover] Ordered an eight foot
cardboard cut out of Will Ferrell
and arranged for it to be
sent to my mother's house.
- [Voiceover] A friend of
mine has gotten absurdly drunk
and ordered things on Amazon.
She likes to be surprised.
12 vibrators later and she's
finally started canceling
the orders because it is
literally always a vibrator.
- [Voiceover] I woke up one morning after
a hell of a happy hour to
see an email confirmation
from around 3:30 AM for my
purchase of fencing lessons.
(swords clink)
- [Voiceover] My best friend and I woke up
one morning to an email confirming
our purchase of tickets to see Hanson.
(screams)
I'll admit I love Hanson but this was
the worst show due to the other fans.
No one should have an "MMMBop" tattoo.
No one.
- [Voiceover] One
Saturday night, I decided
that instead of going to
church in the morning,
I would order a package of
1,000 communion wafers online.
- [Voiceover] A Nicholas Cage
as Mona Lisa iPhone case.
I was so proud of drunk
me when it arrived.
("All Night Polka")
(whoosh)
(hinge squeaks)